im phoenix tagesgespräch begrüße ich
jetzt edelgard bulmahn in hannover sie
war lange zeit vizepräsidentin des
deutschen bundestages hat also ein
bisschen erfahrung mit zu bringen für
die spd frau bulmahn nehmen sie uns mit
was ist das für eine stimmung heute was
erwartet uns da heute um 11 uhr wenn da
die wenn da die abgeordneten zum ersten
mal zusammenkommen ja das ist natürlich
eine wirklich spannende stimmung nicht
angespannt aber doch ein bisschen ich
glaube ich für viele neue abgeordneten
ist ein wenig aufregung es ist ja
wirklich das parlament die herzkammer
der demokratie in die man dort eintritt
und jedem wird sicherlich bewusst sein
dass sie jetzt in zukunft wirklich
ganz wesentlich die rahmenbedingungen
unter denen viele menschenleben auch
gestalten mitgestalten können und
deshalb sie ist glaube ich so etwas wie
eine freudige erwartung die stimmung die
heute vorherrscht wir haben es gerade
schon gesehen es ist ein riesiger
bundestag
736 abgeordnete die bulls steuerzahler
kostet das mehrere hundert millionen
euro dieser größere bundestag hätte man
da nicht was daran tun müssen in der
letzten legislaturperiode sei abzusehen
hätte man das wahlrecht nicht ändern
müssen ich sage ich auch versuche
gegeben in der letzten wahlperiode hier
zu einer änderung zu kommen um wieder
der eigentlich angedachten zahl sich an
zu nennen das ist etwas über 600 aber es
ist leider nicht gelungen hier ein eine
verständigung zwischen den verschiedenen
parteien zu erreichen ich bin aber
sicher dass das gelingen wird und es
offen gesagt muss es auf gelegen in
dieser oder in der übernächsten
legislaturperiode gut wäre es in dieser
legislaturperiode
jetzt wird es ja es ist etwas weiblicher
der bundestag wenn auch nicht zur hälfte
weiblich aber das präsidium wird sehr
weiblich seien neben herrn kubicki sind
vor allem frauen die da zur wahl stehen
glauben sie dass das so ein bisschen was
verändern wird vielleicht die
debattenkultur sich verändern wird ist
dass ihre hoffnung ich glaube dass die
debattenkultur sich verändert touch und
über den letzten jahre als ich in den
bundestag das erste mal gewählt wurde
januar 87 damals hatten wir nur einen
anteil von 15 prozent frauen im
deutschen bundestag dass wir jetzt doch
schon seit einiger zeit zumindest ein
knappes drittel oder ein drittel haben
hat wirklich die debattenkultur
verändert es hat vor allen dingen auch
die themen priorität
verändert diese themen die gesetzt
werden die im bundestag die eine rolle
spielen da merkt man den einfluss dass
wir deutlich mehr frauen sind im
bundestag schon aber ich sage ihnen auch
ganz offen einen ein drittel reicht
nicht in die frauen stellen 50 prozent
der bevölkerung und von daher müssen es
noch mehr frauen seien und dass ich das
jetzt in einem präsidium zeigt dass wir
ja fünf frauen im präsidium haben werden
das finde ich persönlich ausgesprochen
gut und ich glaube es zeigt auch dass
frauen einfach gestalten wollen und
zusätzlich große hoffnung ja
eine fraktion hat auch einen kandidaten
aufgestellt die fdp fraktion dass es
bisher nicht gelungen ein auf die
kandidaten zum bundestags vize
präsidenten zu wählen wahrscheinlich
wird es auch heute nicht gelingen was
sagen sie dazu manche behaupten ja oder
sagen ja es ist natürlich das recht
einer fraktion einen bundestagsvize
präsidentin zu stellen das wird aber ja
nicht erfüllt in diesem fall es gibt
keine keine rechtliche grundlage
sondern es wird zwischen den fraktionen
vereinbart wie er sich das präsidium
zusammensetzt entscheidend ist dass die
person die im präsidium das parlament
vertreten die ja nicht nur über die
tagesordnung beraten sondern die und die
sitzung leiten sondern die das parlament
das heißt die demokratische vertretung
der bundesrepublik deutschland in der
öffentlichkeit innerhalb deutschlands
aber auch nach außen hin im ausland
vertreten das ist schon wichtig dass es
von daher personen sind die wirklich zum
einen auf dem boden des grundgesetzes
stehen die wirklich auch mit
leidenschaft für diese demokratie
eintreten die überzeugte kommentare sind
und danach muss man entscheiden das ist
entscheidend dafür ob ich eine person in
das präsidium wählen oder nicht
blicken wir gemeinsam noch mal auf die
zuschauertribüne jetzt da wird die alte
regierung platz nehmen die heute ihre
entlassungsurkunden auch bekommt so ist
es so gehört zum ritus da wird angela
merkel sitzen da geht ja eine ära zu
ende wie blicken sie zurück auf diese
zeit unter angela merkel
diese zeit hat sicherlich gerade auch
wenn ich mit blick auf die beteiligung
vertrauen das beurteile er wirklich das
bild verändert es ist glaube ich heute
völlig unbestritten dass eine frau auch
an der spitze
einer regierung ein land gut leiten kann
und angela merkel hat in diesen jahren
sicherlich wirklich auch immenses
geleistet
manchmal hätte ich mir ein bisschen mehr
drive und wirklich auch zupackende art
gewünscht aber ich will auch nicht ihre
verdienste in irgendeiner form schmälern
sie ist eine person die wirklich auch
viel zu viele kompromisse
erreicht hat in ganz schwierigen zeiten
auch dieses land gut geführt hat und von
daher wird sie heute sicherlich auf der
tribüne auch mit ein mit vielen
erinnerungen dort die
konstruierte neukonstituierung des
bundestages begleiten vielleicht auch an
ihre erste sitzung des bundestages
zurückdenken aber sie kann sicherlich
sagen dass sie in diesen jahren wirklich
eine menge hingekriegt hat und viel
geleistet hat und große verdienste sich
erworben hat ein schönes schlusswort
frau bulmahn war dass die jeweilige
vize-präsidentin des bundestages ganz
herzlichen dank bitte